[Music]
we've been talking about that big las
vegas sporting weekend it actually
begins tonight with the league cup title
match and this one is a rivalry kind of
think of it as a game between maybe uso
usa versus mexico chris matthews is live
tonight at allegiant stadium with a
preview for us chris
well thank you very much denise i'll
tell you what exciting we're talking
soccer here on a wednesday in las vegas
exciting times you know the eight teams
four on the mls side four on the league
mx side has been whittled down to the
final two it happens here in vegas now
they didn't have this league's cup in
2019 excuse me in 2020 because of the
pandemic but in 2019 it was held in
vegas again out at sam boyd stadium and
cruz azul won that now you think of las
vegas the desert city maybe not a rich
soccer history but you would be wrong
because there is a rich soccer history
in las vegas in fact you go back to the
1970s the great pele once played right
here in las vegas now more recently it
was in 2013 make that 2012 in las vegas
hosted the best side in the world when
real madrid and cristiano ronaldo played
santos laguna now 28 thousand showed up
to see that match in 2013 a classical
match between club america and chivas
which led to a fight it was a one goal
game late it led to fights in the stands
so vegas really has a rich soccer
history just last month 61 000 showing
up for the concacaf gold medal match
between usa and mexico and usa one now
the leaders of the league mx and mls are
hoping to make this event much more
prestigious within the last 24 hours
they agreed to expand both circuits will
pause their seasons for an entire month
and they'll hold a tournament now each
side the mls and liga mx will take part
in this so instead of just eight teams
vying for the title you will have 47
clubs and
undoubtedly this thing will be coming
back to las vegas for sure to give you
an idea how popular las vegas soccer
here is in the valley just among all the
prep teams there are 40 high schools and
say you have about 120 teams in the
southern nevada area here that means you
have about 2 400 prep kids boys and
girls playing soccer wonder how many
will show up tonight well much more for
you coming up at six o'clock reporting
from outside allegion stadium i'm chris
matthews eight sports now back to you